[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
y mom and if you're anything like me you
believe that a glass of wine at 8:00
p.m. makes you a better mom so pour
yourself a glass
let's talk tonight ordered red wine is
what I like to call from a blonde and I
always drink this wine when I'm around
other adults and like trying to be an
adult and I'm like mmm yes just great
red but it's actually kind of strong and
kind of intense like tonight's topic
tonight we're gonna talk about the worst
parts of childbirth
you thought pregnancy was bad strap
yourselves in again because this is the
Wild Ride there's pain suffering Beauty
disgusting this fluids
I already anticipate the comments you
did made me not want can't anymore and I
don't care because you deserve to know
let's get started Oh like red wine just
so you know I had both of my births in a
hospital so what I'm gonna say applies
to my experiences yours might have been
different but that's all good so let's
go let's start with the worst part ready
it's not what you think it would be
which is pushing out the child it's
actually this little thing called
contractions it's like your body's way
of saying like get this out of me but
instead of being like oh could you like
start getting without your body's like
the best way that I can describe it is
like a chainsaw has gone haywire inside
of you and it's trying to get out it
they get so bad that you will barf on
yourself I literally barf on myself
during a contraction it's bad not pretty
the rest is not much prettier at least
we got that over with next modesty goes
out the window when you are giving birth
you are basically a live vagina exhibit
because it's just a cycle of people
coming in and out of the room checking
on your lady parts there's a woman who
will come in every hour to shove her
hand
and tell you how far open it is okay
there will be a random man walking in
like lift up my hospital gown be like
you'll write something down and leave
and I'm like can you at least tell me
your name if you're gonna be looking at
that but the worst part is you don't
even care at that point I was like you
can look as long as looking is gonna
help me get this out
next the floodgates your water does not
break like in the movies lot of the time
you will go into labor first and then
your water will break at the most
inconvenient time so in my first labor
my water decided to break as the
anesthesiologist was sticking in the
epidural needle and that's like the most
key part because if he misses with that
needle we could potentially [ __ ] me
or kill me and so he's there just like
my body's just like there you go and
then with a second my water broke as the
nurse was hunched over me checking
because I wasn't progressing and she
wanted to like get a closer look just
like I blasted her in the chest she was
like oh I'm like the waters crashing
around the bed and she wrote on her
chart copious fluids because she said
that that was the most she's ever seen
in her I'm sorry Linda
I blasted you with amniotic fluid I'm
this one's for you
so speaking of epidural the epidural is
like medically sanctioned hardcore drugs
and I don't do drugs but whatever's in
epidurals I'm sure they sell that on the
street cuz I was tripping balls on my
epidural with both of the epidurals
I've collectively said some of the most
embarrassing things that I've ever said
in my entire life I was telling the
nurse about my love for Rick
Springfield's but I was telling the
anesthesiologist in front of my husband
how much I loved him you wanna do
married I just love you so much it's
like waking up the next morning after
being totally wasted and texting
something really embarrassing to your ex
you like wake up from the epidural and
you're like
what did I say oh I'm very grateful but
I will never be able to look any of
those people in the eye okay and even
know I liked Rick Springfield until I
had my second son oh wow
which brings us to the last topic the
fear factor tell birth is probably the
most terrifying thing I've ever
experienced in my life
because you go into this completely
unknown territory with a plan you have
your birth plan but once you're in the
trenches of childbirth your birth plan
is not necessarily what's going to work
to get the child out for example with my
youngest his heart rate completely
dropped as I was pushing him out I have
no idea what was going on it was all of
a sudden just pure chaos and a million
people rushed into the room the doctor
pulled out a suction thing just sucked
him out of me and handed him off to some
other people I didn't even hear him cry
my husband didn't get to cut the cord
and my first words when he came out were
is he dead because I thought that he had
died luckily he did not but it's the
most terrifying thing of all time I'm
not trying to scare you I'm I just think
that everybody should go in knowing
exactly how scary it is my hope is that
by telling you that it's going to be
scary that makes it a little less scary
every mom whose birth their child has
gone through this and you're gonna be
okay you're good you great on a brighter
note once you have the baby out that's
when the really scary and awful parts to
heart is you have a kid you think
childbirth is gross
ty raising a kid you think childbirth is
scary try raising a kid but I'm just
kidding they're actually their blessings
it's beautiful it's wonderful kids are
just blessing it's like 50% of the time
so that's all I got for today I'm Hannah
your friendly neighborhood wine mom and
if you have a birth story that you would
like to share I would love to read it so
leave it in the comments because I love
hearing about other woman's birth
stories just all the different crazy
funny stuff that happens I don't know
about you but this video has made me
super super hungry so I'm gonna go eat
some pizza hope you are inspired to have
more babies till next time
five five go go away
[Music]